thank you very much
so a few disclaimers first this has
little to do with the brain it's not an
attempt to do anything that is
neurologically uh plausible
the second one is this is work that we
did a few years ago
and it's extremely mathematical so i'll
of course give intuitions
but but uh i may or may not try to go in
the math
and um it's going to be hard for
everybody me included because it's
we haven't i we haven't looked at this
for a few a few years
the the story of this is i was
discussing with the arena
and in no way had i ever thought of
applying this to
um a neural network because we thought
about this in very different contexts
but then you know talking to arena it
seemed like yes actually this is
relevant
and thinking slightly more i do believe
this is relevant so
my goal here is to you know spread ideas
out
there are lots of uh uh people with very
agile brains
in the audience and hopefully some
things will happen
and another disclaimer actually the
person who has really been leading this
line of research is not me
it's julia mirale and we
with a very um brilliant student after
mention we contributed something that i
think is extremely important
but we contributed something building
upon a historical line of research by
julia mirad
he had the test of time award at icml
for his 29 2010 paper
so i'll i'll talk a bit about you know
very general things about gradient
descent and stochastic gradient descent
and then i'll talk a lot about metroid
algorithms and there are the same class
of algorithm that alternating
uh a minimization and i'll explain why
so let's start with gradient descent
this is a picture of
upgrading descent uh really you know
gradient descent we're minimizing we're
trying to optimize on w
to minimize some form of cost function
and we're just iterating by
uh you know
modifying w with something that is
proportional to the gradient
of the last uh on w
this works well but if we're not well
conditioned
then the problem is the gradient is not
pointing in the direction of the minimum
even in the case
of a simple quadratic function and then
things
start going bad and you get these kind
of oscillating behaviors or you need to
decrease the
step size a lot and then you get very
very slow conversions
uh and really the reason is because if
you look at the local gradient
uh i can use pointers or i can move
around
uh if you look at well they're both as
bad
using pointers they're moving around you
look at the local gradient right it's
not in the direction of the minimum
and so you're just all selected and the
solution is well known you do something
that is second order
so basically you look at the curvature
and with the curvature you can correct
your
your your gradient this uh works
extremely well
if you're in uh batch settings and there
are all kind of
uh very good ways of approximating the
the hessian
uh in online settings it's a much much
much more difficult problem
as far as i'm concerned it's not solved
at least it's not solved in a very
robust way
and you should ask people like nicolas
uh
right exactly momentum gives you a lot
of solution this trivial problem would
be solved by momentum
i'm just i'm just giving the intuition
right i'm not claiming to do a
state-of-the-art
ungrading descent but this uh as far as
i'm concerned this is an important
problem
stochastic gradient descent uh the idea
is uh
your uh cost function is the sum of many
uh identical uh cost functions so you
can think of it as the expectation
uh uh on a random distribution uh of
uh uh an individual cost function and
then if you rewrite the gradient descent
uh in terms of expectation then the idea
being that uh
you are going to use a cheap estimate of
this expectation
and i will call this our first
butchering uh you're
basically if you sub-sample uh uh the
sum
uh you get an unbiased uh estimate with
more variance and this variance will be
problem
but uh then uh you can still
still get convergence and something
that's crucial is that
uh you need to decrease uh the step
sizes
in a certain way so other disclaimer
i'll be talking about
optimization so minimizing functions i
will not be talking about generalization
and there might be differences you
especially with
complicated objects like neural nets you
might not want you
you want to be careful about how you
optimize this is not what i'll be
talking about today
okay uh so
this is great in descent people have
pushed this
much much further and this is the
workhorse of deep learning these days
so it you know has challenges
well-known one is vanishing gradients so
in in recursive neural networks but also
in very deep networks the idea being
that you know
you're propagating the information
across many many many many layers and if
those layers are not well conditioned
then they just information just vanishes
this is a conditioning problem right it
means that if you have a very very deep
net the uh modification that you need to
do
at the bottom of your deep net at the
end
the weights of your your entrance layer
uh
may have a very different scale than the
one that you need to do at the output to
have the same delta on the output okay
so extremely different scalings
extremely different scalings means
conditioning problems
extremely different scaling is what we
have here we have two variables that
have very different scalings
okay so this is a conditioning problem
people have
looked at it as a conditioning problem
and have contributed very uh interesting
stuff that i will not
talk about another um
advance that i claim is related is batch
norm
i like the view that batch norm somewhat
controls conditioning
and there has been some conceptual
results that show this
and the way i like to think about it is
i like to think about a deep linear
network a deep linear network is
something i
understand better than a deep non-linear
network
so basically i've got a product of many
matrices and the problem is that those
matrices
i'll get these same exact outputs if one
goes
very big and the other one goes very
small okay so i've got this
this instability and this instability if
it happened
will create a bad condition so if you
know one layer has become huge
and another layer has become tiny it
means i don't have the same natural
scale
on both layers so i have a conditioning
problem and batch norm
somewhat addresses this all right so
that's all for stochastic right in this
set now i want to move to something
different which is major minerals
class of algorithms that are
pretty much the same thing as alternated
optimization and i'll explain why
and i'll immediately uh say that
the miral 2013 paper
really proves the
convergence of those class of algorithms
in stochastic settings
unfortunately it's an extremely
technical paper and so it's
not read a lot i mean it's really hard
to read
but the core results are there though
the delta that we made with the
2017 publication is important and
most of my talk will be focused on
matrix factorization
the actual reason is because this is
what we were interested in when we did
this
on the other hand matrix factorization
may or may not be an interesting toy
problem to look at for deep learning
so you know we have one matrix y and
we're trying to decompose it
in a product of two matrices
another thing i should say is that this
is very deep links to online em
algorithms
which i will not talk about and we're
taught we're taking a different approach
to them is
we're we're not computing expectations
we're just
computing measurement and minimums
i would like to believe that one of the
benefits is that we're not con
we're not as conditional to data
distributions
and but there are drawbacks
so uh matrix factorization
uh the class of problems we were looking
at is
written as such so we have a cost
function
uh and a penalty and the cost function
here i'm taking the simplest one we can
work with more complicated one but i'm
taking the simplest one
this can be solved by stochastic
gradient descent i just you know
i'm optimizing on e and s i just take a
weight vector
uh w that is the concatenation of the
vectors of e and s i can compute the
gradients
like i saw this with stochastic
optimization this
is typically done for recommender
systems where you're doing matrix
factorization people
are often using stochastic gradient sets
we approach this in another setting we
approach this in the setting of brain
imaging
so the setting we're interested in
historically
uh was with huge matrices and one of the
challenges was that they were huge both
ways
uh and the the naive way of tackling
this is
alternating minimization i will first
minimize i will you know so block
coordinate descent
all this is the same thing so i will
uh i will minimize with respect to e
keeping
s constant and then minimize with
respect to
s keeping e constant and i'll alternate
and this hopefully will converge because
each time
i'm decreasing the cost okay now this is
a terrible strategy because it's a batch
strategy you need to go over your data
all the time so if you've have
somewhat large data it's incredibly slow
so what junior mikhail did in 2010 is
that he rewrote this problem as an
expectation
basically uh writing the frontness norm
as the sum of
individual norm on each sample okay
because the travel storm is separable
and then said well this sum
is something i can consider as an
expectation so i have an expectation of
a sub-problem
and then i will optimize i will use
stochastic optimization on this and i
will optimize on sub samples
however the detail is the the the
this algorithm is not a stochastic
gradient descent
and i'll go i'll go into this because it
matters a lot
so uh if you do this then you can tackle
a matrix factorization in an online way
where you're
streaming the data and you're each time
optimizing part of the problem
so you need to optimize fully one of the
two matrices and partly another
only one of the two matrices partly
another and the matrix that you need to
fully optimize
is the matrix that so you've got two
matrices so they
they're sometimes called loading
and dictionary i mean there are
different vocabularies but
one of the matrix is
as is sample wise you know you have one
one value of the matrix per sample
and the other is not okay it's the
latent factor
basically so what you're going to do is
that you're going to give up on
optimizing well the sample wise matrix
but you're going to optimize well
the latent factor okay that is the core
trick
and then the end of the day you know
there's no free lunch you don't have the
sample wise matrix but you have the
latent factor
okay so this works
well i mean you go from something that
is intractable to something that is
very tractable and
on on on a brain date it works that's
not the point here
so what we did this was too slow for us
because our matrix is huge in both
directions
and so what we did was that we also
sampled in the other direction so
basically each
observation was made of a huge number
of uh features because it was brain data
and it was like a million
dimensional uh data and so what we did
was we sub sample in this direction
by the way i already presented this in
mila a couple years ago
but hopefully the audience is a bit
different
uh so what we did is we subsampled the
rows
and by doing this we're quite
quite butchering our cost function we're
getting approximation of our cost
function
and and the thing is we can show it
still works
and i'll go over this but if we show it
still works we can also know
how to like have a good algorithm
that uh converges extremely fast so we
get 10 times speed up
uh with no like
implementation tricks this is all python
code
probably i'll tell you later but
probably but i'm not totally certain you
would have to
you would have to add i mean i'll go in
the in the algorithm but basically
you've got you've got two steps
you would probably need to add a
projection step uh on the
orthogonal matrices and this will add
cost yeah yeah yeah that would be in the
bcd step
okay so 10 times speed up uh that's
great we're happy
and uh uh so empirically
we compared this to a stochastic
gradient descent
and so the two things there one is it
did go
much faster than stochastic gradient
descent on a variety of problems
uh and the second thing is that the
we don't have really to set a learning
rate and i'll go back
to this detail but what i'm showing you
here is
the best convergence grid searching for
the learning rate of sgd
this is a bit annoying in practice
because you have this hyper parameter
that is hard to to to
to set so this is one example on brain
data that
and oh the when i'm showing those curves
i'm
showing the cost function on new data
because we're doing stochastic
optimization
so what we're really interested in is
optimizing the expectancy of the cost
function
so the way we validate this is by
showing new data okay
uh so this is applied to a variety of
different problems with different
constraints and different penalties
uh and different kind of data you've got
brain data
uh you have hyperspectral imaging
satellite data and what you can see is
that often
but not always we're vastly
faster than stochastic gradient descent
not always you can see here that it's
not the case this data by the way is
smaller as you can see
that uh for instance this this data okay
this is on recommender systems so
different
kind of data it's sparse it's not dance
uh
and uh what we can see by the way i
i forgot to say this is uh time this is
not epoch
and the reason this time in the epoch is
what we're really doing is that we're
really doing
many steps that are much faster but have
more variance
okay where once once again we're
butchering our cost function
i'll come back to this and so this
allows us to do many steps
and the question is not you know in
terms of how much data we've said
we've seen if if we're trying to
optimize how much data we're seeing
then we shouldn't be doing this we're
trying to optimize time we're trying to
go faster
and okay so what you're seeing here is
that the
bigger the data set the more the gain
and the reason is
is quite common in stochastic
optimization the bigger the data set the
more
likely you you are to have redundancy
than the data
and this only works because we have
redundancy in the data because we're sub
sampling
very large sums and by sub something
very large sums we're getting
unbiased estimates with a larger
variance okay
so technically the way
uh the original miral algorithm works is
the following and i apologize
i have different notations than before
sorry i i was quite sick this week and
didn't have much time to work on that
presentation
uh so we're going so we're streaming yes
from a va e yeah i mean sure same thing
va vae is i mean all these things are
laid in factor models
well okay no let's say autoencoder
because variational
then then i claim there is a bit of a
difference
do you fit auto encoders using batch
algorithms
you can but do you do it
it's it's very slow because if you need
each step of your gradient you need to
look at
your whole data if your data is big it's
going to take forever to converge
yes yeah difference between batch and
mini batch
sorry what i call batch maybe we have a
vocabulary product what i call batch
is i look at the full data what i call
mini batch is i look at a subset of the
data
no that's a valid question why do i want
these topics that's a very valid
question
and and i mean there's there's so yeah
it's good so it's basically for me it's
the whole point of the workshop here is
we can say
sgd works it's true experience has shown
that at least for dictionary learning
these things work massively better for
several reasons one of them is you don't
need to to
to set a learning rate the other one and
i'll come back to it is it's got a
better memory and that's actually
related by the way
the fact that you don't need to set the
learning rate in the better memory
and what we're going to show later is
that
we can butcher the way we do our updates
if we control
a bit what we do we can still converge
and this is really what we're showing
here so with these things we're really
doing
very approximate updates and the reason
we're
doing very approximate updates is that
we're looking only at a subset of the
features
you give me a a data that has a million
features
i'm gonna look at
a hundred thousand which is a lot but as
a subset
and i will update my weights only based
on this
so in no way have i computed a proper
error term
whether it's with gradients or with
other things
and and as i'll discuss the the thing
about this class of algorithm is that it
can be robust to this
so this is why we're getting speed ups
this is a good example
the reason we're getting speed ups is
that well one reason there are two
reasons
i'll come back to this but one of them
is that we can be robust
to pre-brutal approximations
and still converge so we can see more
data at a time
depending upon
how crazy it is may or may not
completely agree and this is why back
when we did this we thought this is a
cute idea it can works on a
bunch of problems which are basically
matrix factorization with the variety of
losses so
on gamma question it also works but it's
not a general thing
however you know talking to arena i'm
starting to think
it's all down to and i'll go a bit more
in the detail but it's all down to can
we
basically can we get some good
approximation of the loss
if we have a lot of structure it's easy
if we don't have a lot of structure
it requires more thinking
and to me this is a completely open
question but
i'll present fairly theoretical results
that tell us that if we get a
decent approximation of the loss and the
decent doesn't have to be very good
then we can convert and the real
question is going to be can we get these
decent approximation of the loss in a
way that
saves a lot of compute time because if
we can
we won if we caught we lost
i'm not i'm not claiming this is useful
for neural nets i'm claiming
we should look at it which is a
different thing
yeah absolutely no no it's linear
there's no non-linearity
in here
right right but there's no in terms of
in terms of the forward pass there's no
non-linearity
yes we need we need yes we need we need
the problem to be decomposable to apply
this exact
uh trick but the reasons that i'll show
are much much much
uh broader than this okay so basically
if the loss is decomposable so if we if
it's a
sum on on if it's a double sum then we
can
immediately benefit from this but the
theoretical results that we have are
much broader than this
of course now the challenge is going to
be can we instantiate them in
a good setting
so yeah so i mean the way the way this
this the way the mira the original
uh algorithm works and it's it's useful
to to understand it a bit
is that we're going to optimize
a subproblem and the sub problem here is
computing
the uh the loading of the dictionary
on a batch of data or in a single
instance so on a mini batch or a single
instance i should be
careful with my terms and this
here it appears like this and it could
appear differently if i had a different
loss okay
and then we're updating what i will call
the surrogate function and this is where
it's
it's important so
this resembles the loss i'm trying to
optimize
it resembles the uh uh
the from this norm but that is super
important
it is not because it would be
if i had the optimum alpha the one that
i have at convergence one
but i don't have it so what i'm doing
is i'm using sub-optimal alphas
and i'm just using the sum over the cost
of my algorithm of sub-optimal alphas
because these alphas are sub-optimal
this cost
is above my
true the thing i'm really trying to
optimize okay
that is that is the crucial part so
because i have suboptimal
latent factor i have a cost that is
above
so i will call this my surrogate cost
and
this is really the big difference with
greater distance is we're we're
optimizing store gate costs and we're
explicit about this
yeah i know yeah yeah it is it is it's
just
and and then there's there's a trick and
arena is same same formulation then
there's a trick
and and this trick is crucial and this
is where
we might break is that this cost here
is uh it's it's a simple from this norm
so it's easy to expand uh with you just
expand it and there's a trace that
appears
but most importantly this is only
this is fully characterized by two
things the covariance of the dictionary
and the projection of the dictionary on
the data so two things
and with this if i know this i fully
know my cost
so this is a specific case this is a
really easy case right
it's linear it's too normal
you need for it comes from
and i'll come back to this it comes from
if you want to provably converge
to the optimum you need a variance
reduction mechanism
it is your memory
exactly and you need this for a variance
reduction because if you don't need this
it's like stochastic
without decreasing the learning rate you
will get to a certain point of the
optimum but then you'll
go around which may or may not be a
problem for neural nets
but if you're really trying to get the
optimum then you need this
well and and that's where the proofs are
interesting is that by going on the
proof we
improve that and
so the thing is so that's crucial so
these two
two things are the covariance of the
dictionary and the projection of the
dictionary on the data
if we know them we fully can
characterize our loss
and so this is a big difference with
stochastic great in this set is because
we know our loss
we basically are gathering sufficient
statistics
of the loss of accumulating on the data
now that's also the drawback
this is not something as not a toolbox
it's convenient to instantiate a
stochastic gradient design i need to
know more
i need to know what are the sufficient
statistics of my loss i
well if i want to have it provably
converge now there's a difference i'll
be talking about
you know theoretical results and
conversions sometimes
we can get over them and still have
things that work even if we don't have
proofs right
the first
layers
that's your memory
that you discounted oh the fact that you
discounted is how you get your variance
reduction
if you don't do this you will convert to
variance level
so why is this important this is this is
crucial actually this is the big
difference with creating descent
we so the picture you need to have in
mind is that of a stochastic major
neuron so we're basically we're taking
our complicated loss function and we're
going to approximate it with something
where we approximate it with here that's
it's the simple case right
is this quadratic function where
we are using it so this one where we're
using something that has
stored the memory the big deal
is that this is second order because
here
we have the covariance of the data so
the big deal is that this is robust to
ill conditioning
now this will work only if you can write
those sufficient statistics
no free lunch okay and once we have this
we minimize the surrogates
and anything works right we can use
greater than this set we can use block
coordinate descent we can use closed
form if we have closed form anything
works okay
so this is this is the original 2010
paper
and then julia proved it that it's more
general that it works
in his 2013 paper he proved that it
works
for uh of not only for squared loss and
everything but it's nice to understand
it for square loss
sure
now the problem with momentum is it's
completely it's
it's completely blind to uh
to the to the actual full hessian okay
the momentum
of strain is a physicist momentum is
like is like putting friction in an
oscillator
right it will avoid the oscillation but
it's not
rescaling the different directions this
is much closer because
the matrix a is the converges to the
covariance
of your variables
so so it is very different this is
technically it's not a great in this
sense so i can't say it's a second order
algorithm but it's closer to a second
order algorithm
and the only way it can work is because
we're capturing this covariance okay so
what we did
now i'm going to go back so this is the
original paper now i'm going to go back
to what we did
and what we did was that we uh uh we
used the fact that our loss was
decomposable
to uh basically approximate our loss
even further
and so our loss was a sum over samples
but some also over features
we the the the work by julian shows that
you can sub sample
the sum over samples we showed that you
can also subsample the sum over features
okay so we're basically looking at
different features that each were
sampling features each time
now the code becomes horrible and i
won't go into the details
but there's different things so this is
a formalism that you need to put forward
to be able to study the algorithm
the some important things are in green
and there are gain variance reduction
so these things are necessary
to not completely forget the past and
the fact that you're we're subsetting
features but we're you know we're going
to see features again every once in a
while
and so basically we want to average what
we've seen back then
uh and what we now see so we're going to
be updating
those uh uh those covariances and
projections
but with some averaging factors
no it's not in the icing paper the icml
paper did not converge because it did
not happen
it converges it converts to epsilon but
after
epsilon we didn't we didn't know it what
was
that will be the memory for computer
learning but without waiting it probably
doesn't work
and so yes and there's a fundamental
thing is when i i presented this to
google brain
uh i don't remember who but somebody
doing uh
uh ireland google googleborn told me
yeah basically it's the same kind of
stuff
you have in rl dona is in
the room and i don't know anything about
rl uh so i can't tell but basically told
me oh yeah yeah the equations are very
similar
i don't know i'm sorry
so it's not but we're using in their
proofs and those proofs are horrible
and and actually uh engineering didn't
but in the proofs we're using techniques
the martingale techniques uh uh that are
quite common in rl apparently
because you need you need to take an
account your past i'll
i won't go too much in the details
partly because i can't
but anyhow those the only thing i want
to point out is that those green factors
are important because they
they've taken account of cost and
exactly what gives me a good circuit
function
yeah okay and so by the way this is the
difference to the uh i say well paper
is that if we don't do the average
estimators
we don't prefer as you can see so this
averaging is
useful but only to converge to very
tight precision
this is published this is a 20 it's it's
the 20
uh uh it's it's a 2018 paper in
transaction and signal processing
it it's published yeah all right to go
back to the paper to do those slides
yeah but it didn't have this the icml
paper had i'm getting lost in my slide
the sml paper had this but not this
the difference is my nerve but sometimes
it matters
uh i don't know
i no i don't know we haven't looked and
this is
in this is not so the reason why we're
not looking is tooth
we're optimizing an expectancy when
we're optimizing the expectancy the
the proper way of validating optimize
expectancies
so okay if we
it's a latent factor model we're only
optimizing the latent factors we're not
optimizing
the loadings uh if any the any kind of
controls that we have is on the
expectancy of the optimality of those
latent factors
the way you compute an expectancy that
is unbiased is you draw new data
you can't use the data that you've used
to optimize
so any kind of theoretical results that
you will have are an expectancy
and in practice to test them you need to
to do new data
it's fairly classic
15 minutes thank you
okay so once again why does it work it
works because we're having a majorant of
the cost function
every time and this is a very useful
idea to have in mind and i and and my
real question is
can we repurpose it for other
architectures
like deep ones for instance and then the
question is you know what kind of
majority do we want and then
it's quite open there are many ways and
so arena
did one kind of maturing but maybe we
can do others this is the real question
and this was all proved uh in the 2013
paper
so really the the 2013 paper tells us
that at each step
we're doing a surrogate and i've written
here
it's quadratic because quadratic is easy
but it could be something
else and then we're minimizing this
circuit
minimizing the circuit now what we did
in the 2017 or 2018 paper i don't
remember
is that we said it's okay a survey
doesn't have to be exact it can reproxy
our optimization doesn't have to be
exact it can be approximate
and by the way this actually completes
the proof of the mijan paper because
what junior had seen in his
implementation is that he didn't need to
do several iterations of block
coordinate descent
so basically he does not need to do a
pro optimization
paper
no nobody does it and the thing is we
can prove it works so
back to my point is and i'll i'll
discuss this a bit more detail but what
we're showing is that you can butcher a
lot of things you can put your
your approximation in the cost function
and this is what we should be trying to
use
in deep learning so you know we're
propagating information
can we propagate less information can we
probably get information with delays
i don't know this is somebody that came
a few weeks ago talking to arena i've
never thought about this in the context
of the birding
and the other one is we don't need to
have good optimization i'll put
like numbers on this well proofs on this
later but really important things
is you don't need to have a good
approximation you don't need to have a
good minimization
yes and this is what i'll talk about
this is what i'll mention yeah yeah and
good enough is decreasing basically
these two need to be decreasing and
we'll put math on it and then the math
becomes horrible
but basically they need to be decreasing
this is what so if you want to prove
that you converge and by the way you
might not need to prove that you
converge
if you're doing uh deep learning because
sometimes it's not good to optimize
these things extremely well but if you
want to prove that you converge
uh you need this thing to be decreasing
the the approximation to be decreasing
and the partial organization to
keep getting closer this is easy this is
hard
this is where we need various reduction
we need never because if we don't have
memory
well we're not going to get it cheaply
the problem is catastrophic for gauging
nicely because it doesn't contain
memory whatsoever intuition is yes
proofs is going to be a nightmare i
don't care
but would it work i think yes because
you have a memory term
and then your challenge is going to be
to tune this memory term with
how fast your distribution changes
a good point and
i
i think the answer is both
uh but i'm not sure
okay no the problem is you've got two
circuits that's why you have
you have yes yes okay you have two
surrogates oh god
you have uh the circuit at a given point
and you have the surrogate with memory
so the fact so you need to consider that
you've optimized this thing plus all the
rest in the past
this is the surrogate at
the as it's written here this is a
circuit at the current point
this is a circuit with the member
so very good question one of them
yes exactly and because you have and
because all the others were
were majority the fact that you've
always had
majority means that when you sum over
the path you still have majorities
a sum of majority is a majority
god am i i'm really hesitating to go to
going these things
so really the so the idea being that
you've got two steps
one which is a majorization test is a
step which computes an approximate sure
gate
of the loss function that's kind of the
answer to your question actually of the
loss function close
to your previous weights and sorry
w has become theta here
uh
so and it's in so this surrogate
function is approximate because it is
close
to a true upper bounding circuit
okay that's the first thing so it's
approximate
uh uh surrogacy and the second thing is
is quite simple is you take an
approximate minimum so you can take any
any minimum algorithm
a minimizing uh algorithm that you want
you know according to this sense
gradient descent anything and you can
really stop it
which is nice
okay i basically i went through the
paper and i looked at the assumptions
and here we have assumptions on the loss
function but honestly they're
not interesting because they're quite
classic assumptions they're things like
things are reasonably well bounded they
don't need to be
convex by the way they're reasonably
well-lipped shits so basically they're
well-behaved
but not complex and and there exists
some form of derivative
this gets back to my original question
it does definitely depend on the
cross function so but this is easy the
rest is hard this is easy
sure yes um one thing i wonder about
with this though is they're
uh commenting now and reading his first
name
uh that basically in larger networks you
end up getting
better smoothness in your loss function
so i wonder if this would actually scale
better
on larger problems have you guys
explored that
we've explored nothing i mean this we we
did we did this prediction learning and
then trashed it because our problem was
sold we had a specific problem we were
so
trashed talking in the kitchen to
everybody that three weeks ago is like
darn those results are useful
but in no way did we try this on your
lids
uh well i would i would expect it it
would and the reason is
uh but it's it's even more than this is
the the the
those very large networks they have
redundancy in the weights
and so i we could do things this is why
the ids but we could do things like
update a subset of the weights
but a different subset each time right
because you want your updates to be
biased
uh and the bigger your network i suspect
the more beneficial this is because
you've got more and more redundancy
so intuitively yes but this is the easy
thing the next step is the hard one
all right so what do we have so that's
the that's the stochastic mm so that's
the old thing not the approximate mm
and what it really needs in terms of
concept is the idea of first order
surrogate function where the idea of
first order circuit function is a
function that is well behaved
and matches what we're trying to
optimize
fine and with this enterprise stuff
things converge so stochastic in it but
we we don't yet have an approximate
uh uh majority that's the hard thing
okay so this is the algorithm it's
pretty natural you draw data
you compute a a a surrogate function
which is a majority
of your cost function but that's close
enough you optimize it
and you draw more data
okay now let's get to the approximate
event this is this is really the
interesting thing
this is nice but if you need to fully
optimize everything each time it's going
to be terribly costly
it's like online alternating
optimization
what we have here is online automated
optimization where you don't really
optimize well
and this is interesting so then we need
the notion of approximate first order
surrogates
and oh god
those things are horrible uh the idea
being that the error between
what you're trying to approximate what
you're what you're trying to circuit and
your approximate circuit is
bam
what's that my slide is that
and then you need another thing which is
a crucial
and that's the hard thing that's is the
where the memory comes in
is that you need the error between your
approximate circuit
and your surrogate to vanish
it's a bit technical but the important
thing is that the expectancy of the
error so
technically there are all expectancy
results so it means you can have noise
it doesn't need to
like don't need to always have a good
circuit you can have a bad circuit every
once in a while
so you need the expectancy of the error
to to decrease fast enough
okay and that's the hard thing this is
where you need memory you need these
things if you don't have this you won't
converge
which may not be a big deal because
sometimes you're not really interested
in optimizing things very well
okay so you need this
thank you and then uh god what does this
say yes you need
you need the approximate minimization to
decrease fast enough
and i believe this is easy even though
the proof is a nightmare because you
need
from the past and this is where rl
people are good at
uh but i think this is easy because it
just means
that because you're warm starting and if
you're warm starting any kind of
iterative algorithm when you're warm
starting
it gets closer proving this is hard but
in practice i think this is easy
i think the really hard part is to get
your surrogate function
to get closer and closer and closer to
your approximate target function to get
closer and closer to your real surrogate
function
this is the hard part the rest i think
is feasible
all right back to a bit of intuitions
so we have stochastic minerals so we
grab
data point computer surrogate costs
optimize the surgery and then we have
stochastic approximate
better minimum the surrogate cost
is approximate but it gets closer and
closer and closer to the actual one
the minimization is partial but the area
decreases as we have this
we can reach
okay so basically that's all i have it
gets
pretty brutal in terms of the math and
now i have questions
so the results if we want to take a step
back is
we can optimize approximate majority
it will still work and we can get away
with partial optimizations
it will still work and
technical details are there's
approximate moderates need to converge
on expectancy to the actual ones and
those partial optimization need to get
better with time
so can we apply this to deep nets i
don't know at all
but i think we should try what do we
need we need a decent majority ideally
it should
capture some form of second order
information because this will work much
better it will be robust tool
conditioning
we need a fast partial optimization and
i stress the fast is if we're going to
do back prop
in a in a sequential way it won't be
beneficial
we're just going to be paying this cost
but we can do
things like partial back prop parallel
computing
maybe so
that's one example but maybe we can
think about crazier stuff
i think we should be we should be
thinking about crazy stuff because if we
find crazy approximations we'll gain
speed
that's the whole point i mean the whole
point is if we find crazy approximations
that are very fast we'll go faster
yeah so maybe there's something apply
this
calculate yours
back to doing the backwards that's a
danger
so totally that's a danger so the
question is
if we go to the nitty-gritty detail i
mean i'm afraid we might need to
propagate too much information because
so what we need to do is to propagate
less information
but there has been a bunch of results
including by eugene velilovsky who
showed that
only partial optimizing networks work
well and i i suspect it's related to
this
but the question is the real question is
how do you do this without paying the
cost
other ways of doing this is parallel
computing so
your my intuition but this is i haven't
you know thought about this deeply but
my intuition is you no longer need a lot
of synchronization
dates or just in your activity
in the activity across the networks i
believe that's the interesting thing
this information
and wait updates are exactly optimizing
that circuit
that's exactly each layer has its own
circuit
sure i get that to calculate
intuition is that you can as you say
close your eyes your
cost function in these methods so
hopefully you can get away with back
propagating
less information yeah
that's the i think you know this comes
back to the key question
for biological spell
which um he phrased in
our players workshop as
effectively the question is how high
ranked
boss information at each layer
and the answer so by the way this i'm
done this is question time or discussion
time
and the answer is you can go pretty wild
as long as on the stationary
distribution we'll assume things are
stationary
you you converge to an unbiased estimate
where the variance that goes to zero but
the individual steps can be wild
yeah i wanna i guess the question would
be though i wanna see how far you my
intuition would be you would still need
a fair bit of directional information
every direction is doing a decent
job
so not propagating the air at all is
forgetting the sample as far as but yeah
i think you can partially propagate it
because so the most obvious way of of
implementing this would be to for this
step this step of partial optimization
would be to do to do great in this set
on this and then we've
not gained anything
error to your previous layers you just
need them
randomly or whatever but like they have
to have different protection
we don't have deep architecture in any
way because
so you can play this architecture oh
yeah
so yeah i think we're i would agree with
the arena is that on specific
architecture you can probably say much
more than in general
so if you have resnet then resnet maybe
yes this can be used for resonance
because
there's a specific architecture and you
can start playing with it
like a basement you need to have some
so forward and backwards and you should
add
all right that's kind of work
organization what is those
don't have this issue
so another another point yes it's useful
to see the network has exactly this a
network information diffusing in it
if you start dropping information it
will still work
i think i mean another and another way
forward would just be to be quite
brutally empirical
and start doing things that we find
convenient
in our dates and see if it still works
it won't fully work because for to to
work fully we need this violence
reduction but
you know we can come back to it right
but what you might
what might be interesting is it's going
to be a specific it's going to be
different on each architecture it might
be useful to update only parts
of this hierarchy right which is what
we're doing uh
if you have enough redundancy then your
benefits if you've got a huge
net with a huge amount of redundancy and
you have did only parts of it
this was our situation then you benefit
but i think you need this you need some
form of redundancy and some form of
the fact that computing only part of it
is much cheaper in terms of compute
power
than computing the whole thing or or
you know you need completely new
different ideas based on mm rather than
greater design